rocky and this morning we have an update
on a british couple with an olympic size
goal that captured all of our hearts
around here we showed you recently
how stuart bates and charlotte nichols
set out to compete
or rather complete more than a hundred
olympic events during the tokyo games
they were not expert in all of them but
they did win our hearts it was all to
support a very personal cause
and we have to say they succeeded beyond
every expectation
as our mts tayab reports now wind
surfing
there are only winners at this
two-person olympics
between the tears and champagne a sense
of accomplishment
and relief i'm glad it's done but we've
had the time of our lives
for the 17 days of the tokyo games
stuart bates and charlotte nichols
tumbled stumbled and well fumbled their
way through 49 sports
and 102 events to raise money for a cure
to lou gehrig's disease
also known as als i lost my brother to
this
terrible disease 10 years ago when we
wanted to do
something massive that's never been done
before we came up with this absolutely
ridiculous idea
uh of doing every olympic event in the
17 days of the tokyo games
you're literally in the lap of the wind
they called it the spenny olympics in
honor of bates's brother spencer
who died from als and was an olympic
superfan
it was a tribute of all tributes to her
late son said barry bates
so proud his brother's out there
laughing his socks off
the spend olympics required months of
training a couple even had
real olympians who coached them in
everything from diving
to triple jump karate
and even trampolining but going for gold
in the dozens of events
only came second to raising money with
an initial goal of around fifteen
thousand dollars
they've now raised over a hundred and
eighty thousand in donations
we've got a smile on their faces we're
raising money
and we're getting closer to a fuel
everybody wins
a winning spirit from two amateur
athletes
with olympic-sized hearts to use
for cbs this morning empowers monday
i love it what a great story for a
wonderful cause
it is i mean would you do that i mean
think about it honestly i hope that it
becomes like the ice bucket
challenge where everyone does it um what
kind of jobs do they have
no that's a good 17 days
that's a really good question very
impressive very impressive thank you
mti's